de lujo nos piden que simplifiquemos
logaritmo en base 3 de 27 x y bueno
realmente lo que se refieren es que
utilicemos las propiedades de los
logaritmos para simplificar lo más que
podamos esta expresión y más aún yo creo
que están pensando en una propiedad de
los logaritmos en particular una
propiedad que dice más o menos lo
siguiente y déjenme escribirlo aquí para
que no se nos olvide y veamos cómo
podemos simplificar esta expresión la
propiedad a qué me refiero es la
siguiente la que dice logaritmo en base
b vamos a poner en base be de base de a
por c esto es igual a quien el logaritmo
en base de de a porsche es igual a
logaritmo en base vent de am más lugar
ismo envase b de c es decir que podemos
pasar de un logaritmo a 2 logaritmos si
tenemos la misma base y tenemos dos
términos adentro de un logaritmo
multiplicándose y por lo tanto esto pasa
como el logaritmo del primer término más
el logaritmo del segundo término
conservando la base
bueno esto como lo podremos demostrar o
como podemos ver que es cierto vamos a
bautizar a los logaritmos voy a decir
que el logaritmo en base pda por c es
igual a x esto es lo primero que voy a
decir después voy a decir o voy a
bautizar el logaritmo en base de de am
le voy a llamar james y por último voy a
decir que el logaritmo en base de c va a
ser igual a z recuerda que conservar la
misma base y bueno lo único que estoy
diciendo es la misma verdad estas dos
cosas son cosas equivalentes lo único
que ustedes en dos poniéndole nombres
distintos para que los podamos trabajar
y bueno si a continuación utilizamos el
lenguaje exponencial le voy a decir que
b elevado al x es igual a hace de la
primera igualdad que tengo aquí de la
segunda que tengo aquí si lo paso a un
lenguaje de exponentes voy a decir que
fue elevado a la y es igual a mientras
que de la última me va a quedar en
lenguaje exponencial que te elevado a la
z es igual a c y para esto déjenme
cambiar de color porque estábamos
utilizando el color verde y si no nos
vamos a perder b elevado a la z es igual
hace perfecto estas dos son expresiones
equivalentes estas dos expresiones
equivalentes y estas dos son expresiones
equivalentes dicen exactamente lo mismo
la misma verdad y por lo tanto fíjate
bien ahora lo que voy a hacer yo sé que
de elevado la x es a porsche en pero am
es b al aiem y c es b a la zeta por lo
tanto en lugar de escribir ve a la equis
igualada por c voy a escribir vale x
igualar pero a vale vea ley en porsche
pero en lugar de c voy a escribir ve a
la zeta lo único que estoy diciendo
sustituyendo el valor de ahí el valor de
s que yo ya conozco y entonces que me
quedan b elevado a la x es igual a peu
elevado la ye por de elevado la zeta sin
embargo una de mis propiedades los
exponentes dicen que si tengo en la
misma base en este caso los exponentes
pueden pasar sumando es decir me va a
quedar b elevado a la maceta y aquí
viene algo muy importante tengo que ver
la x es igual a b elevado la maceta y
eso quiere decir que x tiene que ser
igual
ai en maceta pero
es logaritmo base de a porsche mientras
que el logaritmo en base pda y seta es
logaritmo en base en vez de c lo que
quiere decir que se cumple esta
propiedad que es justo lo que queríamos
observar y acabamos de ver cómo se
demuestra esta propiedad de los
logaritmos muy bien ya que tenemos de
propiedades logaritmos y nos acabamos de
dar cuenta que sirve para cualquier
logaritmo que utilicemos que cumpla esta
misma propiedad entonces vamos a basar
nuestro ejercicio de simplificar en esta
misma propiedad
yo tengo logaritmo en base 3 de 27 x y
si te das cuenta aquí tengo
multiplicando 27 por x por lo tanto no
puedo separar utilizándose propiedad de
los logaritmos el logaritmo en base 3 de
27 más el logaritmo en base 3 de x sin
embargo aquí podemos simplificar un poco
porque el logaritmo en base 3 de 27 de
esto podemos obtener un número 3 elevado
a que potencia me de 27 3 por 3 9 por 3
27 esto es lo mismo que 33 elevado a que
potencia media 27 y la respuesta es 33
elevado al cubo es igual a 27 por lo
tanto él
327 voy a poner 3 y a esto le voy a
sumar el logaritmo en base 3 de x porque
al final no podemos saber el valor de x
sin embargo ya simplificamos un poco
esta expresión esto de aquí es 3 es
decir el logaritmo envase 3 de 27 estrés
ya esto hay que sumarle el logaritmo en
base 3 de x este mismo 3 lo voy a poner
aquí más el logaritmo en base 3 de x y
ya está
simplificamos un poco esta expresión y
además utilizamos una de las propiedades
de los logaritmos ya podemos decir
entonces que el logaritmo en base 3 de
27 x es exactamente igual que tres más
el logaritmo en base 3 de x